foreign
listening to you about a year and a half
ago and I got my wife
um recently new wife in like into you as
well so we're both on the same plan and
have the same head on and my question is
um we want to purchase a house within
the next year or two and we've the only
debt we have right now is student debt
that we've been saving
um over the last year and my question is
whether we should pay it off all now
um but wondering if that will affect our
credit score with trying to purchase a
home within the next year well George
you did this yeah uh living this out
have paid off student loans and I bought
a house without a credit score so the
question I think you're asking is how
will it affect it in the meantime if I'm
in that weird in between because when
you pay off your student loans is that
all of your debt
yes that's all our debt yes before he
goes on let me ask you a question do you
have enough money in the bank right now
to pay off the student loan
we do we both do oh okay so you can just
write a check and be done today
and then you want to buy a house about a
year from now
correct okay making sure I have my facts
right okay so your emergency fund will
you have that in place
already or well you need to build that
up after you pay off this debt
yeah so I guess it's kind of scrambled a
total student debt between both of us is
about 56 000. and we have about
um 70 000 in our savings
and I also uh we also have together uh
about 20 000 in individual account with
uh Schwab cool okay good so that'll
leave you with about thirty four
thousand if you cash out what's in that
account that'll leave you thirty four
thousand let's call your emergency fund
somewhere is it 15 to 20 for you guys
three to six months of expenses
yes that's about right okay and then
you've got a little starter down payment
fund with the rest of that money so you
got about twenty thousand towards your
down payment and you got a year to
finish saving up right
yes okay so we're going to tell you to
pay off your student loans today when
you get home tonight go honey we're
getting ready to be debt free watch push
this button
so then in six to 12 months after you
pay off your debt that credit score will
disappear once you close all your
accounts and then your credit score will
disappear now there's a chance you get
the house and they run the credit and
you still have a credit score and it's
probably still going to be a good score
and that's fine you can still get a
house that way but there's really no
your credit score is not going to go
down to you know uh 600 all of a sudden
because you paid off your loans you have
any credit cards open
um we do but we pay it off close them
too close them too that'll keep your
credit score open what we're trying to
do is make have zero credit activity
which will make your credit score
completely disappear in six to nine
months zero credit score sets you up for
manual underwriting which is where they
just check your job check your deposit
like we used to back in the day when
people had since back in the day when
people had to actually qualify for a
mortgage and a monkey can give you a
mortgage Now by looking at a number
credit score and uh but yeah but but we
used to actually make sure people had
the money to pay the bill and stuff and
it's called underwriting the loan manual
underwriting is what's called now as
opposed to not underwriting it and so uh
that's what George did he went with a
zero credit score into Churchill
Mortgage and got a mortgage on his first
home did I have that right yeah and
there was Anthony there's going to be so
many friends and family that go you're
crazy it's going to be so much more
expensive it's going to take forever
it's going to be impossible don't listen
to them because they've never done it
and so I'm telling you it's not going to
be that difficult it's not going to take
a lot more time there's going to be a
few more extra documents and as long as
you stick to that 15-year fixed with at
least 10 percent down you're going to
get a really great competitive interest
rate with Churchill Mortgage not all
mortgage companies know how to do this
Anthony yes so you can't run over it
some stupid butt place like Bank of
America because they won't know their
butt from a home my lender said they
won't do it you got to stick with one
that actually knows what they're doing
yeah you gotta you got to get with
somebody like Churchill they they
because we've endorsed Churchill for
almost 30 years and because I've told
people to not borrow money Churchill has
obviously system-wide learned to and
managed their whole process to being
able to do manual underwriting because a
lot of Ramsey people don't have a credit
score because all of us got rid of our
debt and our credit we don't use credit
or debt but now if you keep those stupid
credit cards open you may end up with a
650 and it's going to screw you up so
you can't half butt do this Anthony
you got to decide is you or isn't you
and you got to lean in and push all the
way through uh so ish will get you in a
middle ground you don't want to be in
and I don't suggest that if you're going
to do that then just stay in debt son
yeah this idea of the credit score is
hilarious to me and once you get the
mortgage there's no reason you would
ever need a score at all even though you
don't need one for the mortgage because
people the only reason people hang on to
it is the wedding what if Dave what if
we need to go into you know if I was um
if I was in the banking business I would
invent a thing that said you need to go
get a credit card so you can build up
this number
so that you can get a car loan so that
you can build up this number so that you
can get a student loan so that you can
build up this number so that you can get
a home mortgage
because you need this number and I would
teach you to worship at the altar of the
great FICO because I would tell you that
FICO was your great provider and that
your life on the planet will be somehow
substandard if you don't have this
number it almost sounds like Revelations
yeah this is conspiracy level Theory
right here and it's the only number that
we obsess over more than our weight
those three digits man we are so
obsessed we brag about it we the culture
not you and me we Dave and I would be a
really sad obsess overweight unless it's
a lack of it I don't share those numbers
Dave okay and my credit score uh I would
share some of my numbers with you but it
wouldn't help either one I'll take one
for the team Dave you can donate some to
me oh but it really is a wild thing that
our culture has become so obsessed so
here's the interest you you know I have
to teach this like and have for 30 years
you could get a million dollar
inheritance your FICO score doesn't want
change one penny it is not an indication
of financial well-being our Financial
Health it's an indication mathematically
the algorithm them by which they used
the math they used to build the FICO
score is 100 based on how much you play
kissy face with the bank
if you don't play kissy face with the
bank if you're not making out with Bank
of America you're not getting a FICO
score
I mean this is not hard people if you if
you if you get a million dollar a year
raise at your office today everyone will
wonder why and your FICO score will not
change one point and you won't care
about your FICO score then yes it will
change one point it's not an indication
you're winning with money you can be
broke but deeply in debt and have an 800
credit score which matter of facts about
the only way to have an 800 credit score
this is the Ramsay show